ciao a tutti quando oggi mi hanno
chiamato a parlare avevo in mente di
dire tutt'altro però partendo dallo
scopo di quello che il ted è quello che
vorrei dire io ho la mia città ho detto
ma parliamo di qualcos'altro nuovi occhi
sono partito da proust che giustamente
ci suggerisce che l'unico vero viaggio
di scoperta non consiste nel cercare
nuove terre ma nell'avere nuovi occhi e
io la mia stessa terra
l'italia la vorrei proporre a voi quando
vi uno sguardo degli occhi diversi la
nostra italia che cos'è la nostra italia
se io dovessi provare a descriverla ora
come ora cosa vedrei un pil che sta
andando a fondo
ok meno 2 per cento l'anno scorso
corruzione che in aumento abbiamo un
grandissimo primato dei 120 miliardi di
corruzione in europa non ne facciamo 60
da soli quindi siamo primi sono grandi
soddisfazioni e tutto sommato tutto
questo senza avere una guida perché
negli ultimi due anni abbiamo cambiato
tra i governi per cui al timone non c'è
nessuno e questo mi fa vedere o come se
dovessi rappresentarla come un'immagine
un'idea un po così
se dovessi vederli con con degli occhi
di un certo tipo e vedrai che alcuni
fuggono da questa italia sentivamo dei
numeri sull'esodo degli italiani che
vanno all'estero
nel solo negli ultimi dieci anni sono
attivi a 300 mila persone l'anno scorso
40.000 il 25 per cento laureati sono
sempre i migliori che se ne vanno no
dalle dalle navi solitamente la rete
prime classi altri restano altri restano
e restano in un paese che tutto sommato
sta abbastanza imbarcando acqua e si
trovano con una bella disoccupazione
quasi al 13 per cento e tante
opportunità che si stanno perdendo
questo all'interno di questo contesto mi
si chiede spesso e volentieri agli start
up per gli start upper cosa sono io
lavoro in questo ambito da alcuni anni e
mi dicono le start up sono rimuove
rockstar
le start up sono quelli che ci
salveranno sono la panacea di ogni male
perché un po come c'è il cantante il
batterista e chitarrista c'è il ceo il
surf il city o il veneto qua cio vuol
dire un'altra cosa poi ogni tanto io
provo a spiegare ma è legato al concetto
insomma siamo sopra il 42 per cento di
disoccupazione giovanile e quindi fa
sfigato dire sono disoccupato sono tutti
start up a rino e quindi sono start
upper bellissimo e tutto sommato adesso
c'è un pullulare di guru para guru è
veramente una cosa incredibile ma siamo
sicuri che essere una rockstar su una
nave che sta affondando un po come sul
titanic abbia senso anche perché poi io
mi domando quello che faccio io è
cercare e scoprire talenti dagli una
mano a realizzarsi in questo caso sarei
come xfactor xfactor su una nave che sta
affondando e tutto sommato fare il
talent scout così non mi pare proprio la
cosa migliore come presentarmi a voi
allora cerchiamo di capire cosa non sono
le start up
vi devo dire una notizia le start up non
sono rockstar
ok ci mancano le groupie semplicemente
questo se io mi dovessi dire quali sono
le nostre gruppi le nostre gruppi sono i
nerd per cui immaginatevi se io dovessi
immaginarvi con una rockstar che cosa
dovrei vedere no no non ci siamo proprio
allora mi domando che cos'è una start up
se io prendessi la definizione di steve
blanc con professore di stanford una
start up e un'organizzazione temporanea
in cerca di un business model scalabile
e ripetibile quindi io non ho la mia
risposta io non so cosa sono io non so
quello che voglio ci sto provando a si
chiama pivot thing in termine tecnico è
quindi una start up è qualcosa che in
cerca e un punto di domanda sui dovessi
spiegare la mia madre di lei una start
up e un punto di domanda è quando poi
trovo la mia risposta trovo il mio
business model scalabile ripetibile
diventa un azienda di valore diventa un
punto esclamativo
wow ok ce l'ha fatta non tutte finiscono
così però queste sono le start up
una start up e come una promessa è una
promessa di diventare un imprenditore io
farò qualcosa di buono per il mio paese
e io sono una persona che aiuta a
mantenere queste promesse
questo è quello che mi aiuta definire
così è per fortuna non sono da solo
quindi il perché però è così importante
aiutare a mantenere queste promesse ce
lo dice una persona che di sicuro non è
un capitalista
ok karl marx in tempi non sospetti in un
bello è trattato che si chiama per la
critica alla economia politica diceva
che ogni nazione è composta da due cose
struttura basis e sovrastruttura più
babau ok la struttura di ogni paese e il
suo tessuto economico tutto il resto
religione filosofia cultura e
conseguenza se il tessuto economico di
un paese è marcio e malato quel paese
non andrà da nessuna parte
e anche così difficile però fare azienda
in italia
noi siamo da un esempio un numero solo
se prendessimo la classifica della banca
mondiale si chiama due in business e
questa questa classifica ci dice conte
facile fare impresa in un paese noi
siamo 65 esimi dopo tonga il kazakistan
e le isole fiji ok e quindi
effettivamente fare cercare risposte
nella nostra nazione forse non è così
facile
quindi ricapitolando noi non siamo start
up
ok noi siamo imprenditori e anche gli
imprenditori che provano a fare impresa
in questo paese non sono imprenditori
perché lo scopo del fare impresa e di
quello che uno può realizzare facendo
bene impresa sul territorio è molto di
più che fare semplice impresa vuol dire
cambiare una nazione vuol dire dargli
una direzione che oggi non c'è
e poi tutto il resto viene di
conseguenza il gabon e sovrastruttura
quindi nella mia visione un po romantica
noi non siamo imprenditori
stiamo combattendo una battaglia in un
paese che non ci vuole e stiamo cercando
di farlo per il bene del nostro bel
paese perché chiediamo che crediamo in
qualcosa di buono al di là di tutte le
apparenza della nave che affonda
noi siamo partigiani la mia visione è
questa ok
ed è una resistenza attiva che deve
portare l'italia dall'italia delle
occasioni mancate siamo arenati
ok ha visto che stiamo usando la
metafora della nave
dobbiamo traghettarla in porto dobbiamo
ripararla e dobbiamo aiutare l'italia a
mantenere queste promesse e gli
imprenditori in start upper a diventare
tutti i punti esclamativi
e questa è la promessa da mantenere
questo al di là del singolo stata perché
posso aiutare questo è quello che stiamo
cercando di fare tutti
questa è la nuova italia in cui all
credo quindi se uno poi mi dicesse che
come vogliamo lasciarci solitamente il
ted finisce sempre con un finale ma il
finale è un video per cui non
preoccupatevi
io quello che dico è alla steve jobs
stay hungry stay foolish stand italy pro
con occhi nuovi che spero di avervi dato
con questo nella presentazione ecco il
video con cui vi lascio che è stato
fatto da altri partigiani
se nei ragazzi d'italia camp e credere
alla regia di fare dissolvenze mero su
di me e dare la parola ad altri
partigiani combattenti
grazie mille